what's up guys so before we start
today's episode i just want to share a
little sponsor with you so today's
episode is sponsored by
bud's life cbd patches uh we've got a
convenient and precise with all the
benefits of cbd oil
without any of the fuss so that's no uh
oral tablets that you have to take
there's no disgusting taste in oil just
a quick patch
yeah man um patches only you've got
three different sizes three different
dosages you've got the 16 milligram
the 32 milligram and the 50 milligram if
you guys are interested
you can use our promo code for 15 off
that's shits and gigs
all the details are in the description
below enjoy the episode
enjoy guys head off i'll bust through
the bedroom what's going on
to see one man get a neck off another
bridge i would howl
i would how so you dirty buggers
what are you doing
what's going on people ah well gone you
men another day another dollar
in it you know everything set you know
how the thing goes um
guys remember jump on that patreon for
that good good
yeah mom links in the description um
jump on the new merch
and see your boys sporting that we got
the thick and we've got that dangly dang
dang dang
um again see ya links in the description
ting's flying off the shelf to jump in
join the uh when the wave man
join the wave it's it's juicy it's
actually juicy it's very juicy the merch
is popping on gas
i'm very happy so thank you thank you
guys for repping us for rocking with us
and yeah man yeah man it's it's like
moving and shaking shaking and moving um
so i'm good what are you saying i'm good
you know
i'm good i'm happy i'm happy you're good
i'm playing run me a funny g please fun
fact of the day
uh you know michael buffer
no let's get ready to oh yeah of course
i do yeah yeah yeah yeah
um obviously well not obviously in 1982
he started his career as a ring
announcer
as everyone may or may not know but he's
the guy that says let's get ready to
rumble
um and he trademark he earned five
thousand pounds per show five thousand
dollars rather per show
up until 1992 where he trademarked the
phrase let's get ready to rumble
and now in 2020 since it's been
trademarked it's worth
he's worth 400 million dollars that's
impossible
just say something else in it because
i'm not paying him just so i can say
this
people are selling it you've sold the
rights to like video games tvs movies
blah blah blah
even like for people that not
necessarily just live in the uk but
if you know charlie sloth um he's a dj
and like a host a radio host
when he's um got people on his show to
start
rapping and stuff the first thing he
puts on is let's get ready to run
i'll swear yeah
yeah he does that so yeah he's trained
he's got p bro
400 million millions just because he
said 20 20.
raw but he's in 1982 that's a long last
time but his brother does the same thing
did you know that i never knew that
bruce buffer oh he does it for the ufc
no way yeah yeah he's the one that does
it for you i think bruce buff is
more live though why is that just in
terms of hype okay
it's just like when he when he sets it
up he doesn't say the same thing
he didn't say let's get right to rumble
now he says like it's time he says it's
time okay
so he'll say he'll announce the don so
red corner blue corner
and then everyone is a little bit
excited and he's like and
it's time and bro
i get hype i'm like this scrap let's
scrap he's sick yeah bruce waffle's live
i'm a big fan but yeah that's he's never
going to get the kind of p his brother's
got oh never in a million years
but fair play though 400 mil he coined
it and that's
it and you used to get paid 5k a turn
how do you even become
a regular ringer i don't have the skills
nor the knowledge to answer that
question
bro i would i would trip up every single
time
the pressure would be a lot for me i
would trip up i was messing with
anyone's name
i'll mess up everyone i will say the
different wrong colors
wrong colored shorts everything for them
i don't know what oh he's a pro i don't
know what
gym you're fighting out of what i said i
was going to take a monster today
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah frieza is jumping
on the mazda high today
i'm so excited with the mango loco
matches the
yeah boys enjoy that sip it deep fam
let it take over you and then you're
just gonna have energy
all right yeah boy gang i'm excited this
is the first time you've heard on the
show
um maybe i don't think so
exciting the asmr slurp
i'm wrong just for you guys mercedes
well to be fair we've tried this one
it's not bad
it's good man if you see me like buzzing
during the shows because of this so yeah
going oh i imagine if you're just here
with him if you're just bang bang bang
bang bang i'll be i'll be gassed i'll be
guys i'll have two
right um so i wanted to talk about i
said at the end of the last episode i
wanted to talk about
heartbreak yes you did men versus women
okay
bros versus yats um
so as a yeah as i said before if you're
new if you're new here
guys i said i mentioned the last episode
that like whenever we get fan requests
and am i the [ __ ] and stuff like
that any simpy behavior
like any [ __ ] or behavior is always
coming from guys like you'd expect
more women i don't know why you'd expect
it but i i would have personally
expected
more women to send us stuff like oh my
man's cheated on me
shall i take him back yeah and all this
stuff
when more time it's it's the guy and not
only does a guy get cheated or he gets
moved together he gets abused
and then and then he's like oh yeah am i
the [ __ ] for locking it off and i'm
like bro
and then they'll always reply like i
don't know if like sometimes we'll
answer in the dm so if we don't get a
chance to answer on the show
sometimes we'll just quickly respond in
the dms just so someone gets an answer
but
even then they're just like oh i know
but still like
i i've never felt like this about a girl
before like i feel like we should just
and i'm like what why do you think that
is like do you think men
struggle harder with the loss of like a
relationship than women
um i i think it may boil down to the
upbringing
upbringing yeah in terms of like
remember the episode we spoke about
love languages and do you think you are
you receive the love or you receive the
love language that you want because you
didn't you didn't
get it yeah so maybe i'm assuming well
not
i'm assuming but yeah i'm assuming that
people
or men go through heartbreak differently
because
maybe they just weren't cuddled as a you
maybe because obviously men are trained
and
nurtured to be men yeah yeah i mean
they're nurtured to be like the provider
the
the one that has to what's the word i'm
looking for like bury his
mental state and bury his emotions and
you know things like that yeah
so men aren't sought as in the way that
women are in terms of that emotional
connection and emotional feeling
because men are apparently supposed to
subdue that
yeah so i feel like maybe sometimes if
they are
truly heartbroken or like truly have
been or truly lost the love of their
life quote unquote
then i feel like that's the reason why
they may take it harder because they've
got no outlet
men have no outlet in my opinion
nowadays anyway
men have don't have no not nowadays but
growing up in that in the last 10 years
men have no no real outlet
or no real or no real safe space to
to act unless like apart from like a
group challenge that's a very vulnerable
one be vulnerable men
it's it's not always the best look
for men to be vulnerable but i feel like
men should
definitely definitely definitely
definitely approach that yeah
i think so oh bro i'm happy to be
vulnerable with you man in the group
chat
i'm that's what i'm saying yeah you feel
safe in a group chat
yeah but but that's out that's the thing
as well that's our group chat yeah yeah
i wouldn't i've got about four different
group chats i would never say half the
[ __ ] i say in our group chat
as i would in another group chat um of
course of course of course
but i also feel like sorry
i also feel like because men
because men do or aren't allowed to feel
as vulnerable as
women are not necessarily aren't allowed
to but are just looked at differently if
they are vulnerable
or are as vulnerable as women it's
almost like a a turn off for women
if you are vulnerable so i feel like
that's why sometimes
men may take it harder or like for
example they use
us as an outlet to type all these things
and blah blah blah blah
i've gone through this i've gone through
that i feel this type of way because i
feel like sometimes
it's expected for women to be able to be
vulnerable be able to feel the way they
are because it's
we've just had that for yeah
so i don't know i don't know if i'm
making sense it could be challenging but
i don't know it's just
it's the way when you ask me that
question that's the first thing that
came to mind fair play so i don't know
i don't know i feel like for me i i i i
can see where you're coming from on your
side
um so we are not even your side just
yeah what you were saying
i feel like i feel like a lot of
the dynamic for men is different
um in terms of not the dynamic design of
the relationship
for men and women is different which
might be why the
recovery process for men and women could
be different as well i definitely think
the
the vulnerability outlet is a big deal
as well in terms of like women will
always have so many out more outlets to
be vulnerable like
women have goat relationships with their
mums a lot of the time and
obviously their friendship groups and
like sisters and all this stuff and like
even people at [ __ ] work
they they're happy to get like just
vulnerable with so like
losing a partner as someone that you can
be vulnerable with is probably not as
that big a deal
because you've got a million other
people you can be vulnerable with but
yeah for a lot of men
their partner is the only is the only
literally
truly vulnerable and i'll say i said
this to someone before i said um
and i've seen i've seen on i think
either twitter on instagram it said
just because i carry it well doesn't
mean it ain't heavy and it's like
a lot of men go through that you know i
mean and
i've personally been through that for
sure like when when you're carrying
stuff like
day to day you're going to work you're
doing your everyday curricular
activities people think you're okay
yeah yeah yeah i'm not saying i'm crazy
inside you know i mean but if people
men go through stuff oh then go for your
money through it gee
i everyone knows i've been from
obviously i'm not smoking it properly on
here but everyone knows i've got because
i say it multiple times
but it's like it's just not it's i want
to say it's frowned upon for men because
i feel like now slowly but surely
nowadays
it's okay for men to open up okay
there's a lot more awareness about it
but it's still
i feel like a lot of guys sorry a lot of
guys would still feel like
oh they're a [ __ ] if they do expose
themselves yeah
so would you say moving forward now like
say if you got heartbroken like tomorrow
yeah
because you have like more outlets to be
vulnerable
within now do you feel like you're you'd
cope better
if you if you've got your heart broken
or would you still think it's just um
i don't think i'd cope
better i just think the healing because
the the breakup is the breakup let's say
i get
heartbreak is heartbreak i'm still going
to feel bad yeah it's not that's not
going to change yeah i just think
the time frame in which i heal will be
quicker yeah
because i've got the outlets yeah yeah
available to you yeah i think that's the
only difference
yeah yeah yeah so yeah i know what you
mean yeah fair play
it's a weird one yeah i'm not really
sure and do you think
here's another thing as well do you
think
people here's an interesting one
imagine if i've got it all wrong okay so
just let's just take a second
and then just put pin in the topic that
we're talking about yeah
how i've said see what how i've said
i've just actually deeped this
see how i've said all the messages that
we get
about simply behavior and then if you
just change the lingo
vulnerable behavior all the messages we
get about vulnerable behavior from men
so maybe they're not any different to
women maybe the women just have
more outlets to send a message to so
they don't need us need us yeah they
don't need two strangers on a podcast
that they've never met
to console them or to give them advice
or to help them through something
because they have all these different
vulnerable outlets
whereas the guys they don't really have
anyone else so the only people that they
can turn to with this stuff is us
makes sense because they they know our
lives for 70 weeks now 71 weeks 72 weeks
so
yeah yeah i've been vulnerable in here
so i'm i'm here i'm here that makes
sense man they feel comfortable
they feel confident they probably don't
feel comfortable telling anyone else
yeah
and we and it's anonymous it's anonymous
to a degree to yeah
because we don't we don't we don't know
them yeah and we're not going to judge
them because we don't we don't know
anything about them yeah so don't really
it's we're like a nice par third party
that's just like this judgment free that
they're allowed to be vulnerable and
stuff like that and maybe you're right
if your
idea is true then maybe that is why we
get all messages from guys hardly any
from girls
because girls don't need us like that
that's a that's a good point
hmm maybe the girls are just doing the
same [ __ ]
in their own yeah [ __ ] chats that
makes a lot of sense to their own family
and friends
because like it's like you brought up
before a lot of women
are close with their mums whereas
obviously yes boys are closer to their
moms or in their dads as well but
they're out in terms of talking about
vulnerable stuff i've personally never
spoken about a lot of the stuff we've
spoken about to my parents yeah oh yeah
it's just not something i do i don't
speak about heartbreak
with with no one but i remember yeah
i remember my dad is
me uh me my brother and my dad have
never had so like my brother and my dad
and me and my dad
we've never had um like a heart to heart
about anything yeah it's just straight
man behavior
none of this sloppy [ __ ] yeah wrap your
tears
bro fam my little brother
goes through heartbreak i've told you
before i know he's the most
logical person you've ever met yeah
until
feelings are involved with a woman he
has no feelings about
anything until a woman is involved when
my brother gets heartbroken he's
distraught
he's distraught and i don't know how to
deal with it
and um i remember my dad messages last
time it happened my dad messaged me
he's uh oh um how's your brother getting
on lazy all right
and i'm like oh yeah yeah i think he's
uh he's struggling but
uh uh he just needs to just you know man
up and
he'll firm it but like yes that's for
the best
like he has no words but you can't turn
to my dad or that kind of stuff no
if you were just if i turned to my dad
like oh my god she did this
cool your business that's your business
i don't know what you want me to say
what do you want from me
and that's the thing though because i
feel like maybe the reason why he can't
potentially give advice because he had
to also
do what i mean he didn't have a dad but
um
so that's even worse in terms of he
didn't have he grew up with his stepdad
my dad's parents died when he was really
young before any of that
he wouldn't have had he wouldn't have
had any of it so he had to buy the ones
he had to buy
it so you can't really give words of
wisdom for that he's got no he's got no
life experience no expertise
it's got nothing to do that he firmed
everything damn
so um yeah it's terrible so yeah i can
understand why
guys struggle they got really no one to
i want to cry
it's tough out here it is man it really
is and i don't feel like
i also feel like it's harsh for men to
be scrutinized
if they do open up because i feel like
everyone's human everyone feels exactly
the same thing because everyone's in
everyone is capable of feeling every
emotion possible i mean so whether it be
male or female doesn't matter the sex
but it's also
obviously obviously just scrutinized
when it's men
yeah i also think as well was like um
even what i was saying about like even
in our group chats like
guys are there like i'm comfortable to
be vulnerable with you man so say if i
got my heart broken tomorrow
i'm comfortable to be heartbroken with
you man um
and express myself but
men still aren't very good at um
helping with the healing process in
terms of
like women will get together
but you know what i mean if i'm going
through it yeah yeah i will jump in the
group chat on blackfellas i'll be honest
with you like
don't cuss me but like i don't know what
to do like i can't eat i can't sleep
like all of this
you might all give me great advice but
no one's going to be like
man let's book a spa
we need we need a weed time we need a
seaweed wrap
and we need last time we really need to
buckle down get some steam
exfoliate and really get down to the
main issue
we need a salt scrub and a chit chat
prosecco on deck
i'm not rejuvenated we'll come back
rejuvenated you don't need that [ __ ]
none of you man aren't going to do that
for man didn't it that's what i really
need
i'm not doing it i got the time for that
no one's got time and energy for that
yeah but yes we'll do the whole nine
yards they'll be like let's heal this
woman
she's been through it let's heal her
that's i guess that's the difference but
again that could be that could also be
our obviously like you said if you were
heartbroken and you came to us in a
group chat that could also be our
masculinity playing a part of it i think
it is
that's the thing i'm saying i think to a
degree guys can only
help so much yeah because
even then like real talk yeah if i'm
even if i thought someone's shouting in
the group like yo
let's big my team let's get a salt scrub
gene let's have a mud bath let's let's
hash it out i would be like
yes but no one's going to say that even
if they thought it
they'd be like people are just going to
see this as a joke like if i put that in
there
i can see jay putting it in there as a
joke yeah and everyone's just laughing
and everyone just like
just carrying on and then we'll just
carry on yeah yeah yeah and then he'll
be like
but i am serious though and we'll laugh
again
and move on and i'll be thinking that
sounds funny
that sounds magnificent but i can't say
that
i already know i say big man i'm not
putting mud on my face
you need to bang bang six years tonight
and it is
it's it's on and you're like it's not
one of these things
before empty that's i'll cry after that
um so yeah yeah i feel like women are
just willing to put
more they not it's not that they're
willing because i know like
my fellows would do anything like human
would do anything to make one of us feel
better but it's just not something that
it's not that you men wouldn't be
willing to do it
it's just not something that would come
up will come up it's just never ever
going to come up whereas women
are like more akin to like this is they
understand that this is what
this person needs to actually feel
better which is why
after a bad breakup and both people are
struggling the the woman is
give it two weeks she's blessed the guy
fronts like for the first two weeks like
he's blessed and then after that he's
suffering
for months i've been better suffering
every once in a while
i think every guy's been there
being alone sucks when you actually feel
that they're not being
oh yeah yeah not being by yourself i
feel there's a difference by being by
yourself and being alone in two
different oh yeah of course
being feeling that alone is awful
awful
it is [ __ ] horrible it's not the it's
not a great feeling man
i've i remember one time i was dating
someone
and i'm being she broke up with me
um you know you know of this person um
yes i know who you're about and then um
like obviously i said i'm being honest i
wasn't expecting a blah blah we were in
my eyes we were cool bro
but um the the places you were both in
at the time just like
our paths weren't meshing so we we had
different directions in life
at that time so obviously she locked it
off one obviously but she looked off and
again like i said i didn't know it was
gonna happen
i was like [ __ ] there's nothing i could
do you know i mean because it's not like
i knew it was coming coming so i could
yeah yeah yeah yeah you just thought it
was wednesday i just
bam i just thought it was midweek i
thought it was hump day
she was like yeah roll through grab a
drink and blah blah blah
boom and i was like cool i have to deal
with this because it wasn't a case of
it wasn't a case of the fact that
okay let me how do i explain this so it
was it
we were dating at a point where
it wasn't even well i wasn't even sure
it was going to go down this direction
we were dating because i fancied her
yeah you know what i mean that's true
yeah i fancy that that's what yeah
yeah yeah um but i didn't know the
longevity of it i was just rolling with
the punches
yeah and it seemed like she was as well
so the more we roll with the punches the
tighter we got it was just fine as it
was um and then i'm being i was like i
said
hump day locked off um and then
she's apparently there were times where
i was just at home
and then bella could just see it on my
face that i was just like
[ __ ] because when something hits you so
quick like
you're in shock you've never got time to
feel anything to process it yeah yeah
i've got time to process it
obviously we talked about it now we
laugh because she's she says there are
times when she came home she sees me
just lying there puppy dog eyes she was
like i'm just on the sofa she's like
nah obviously i i don't know that i'm
doing that
but that's just my natural body trying
to express it it's gonna be better
seeing you like that fan you would
you'll be
a messenger i'll tell you it's on site
see what you did to my boy it's on site
nah i remember where i was when when you
texted me and said this
she locked it i was walking to my car
finished work
walk into my car phone vibrates saw the
thing
i was affected because i re because on
the day i knew she was going to break up
because i told you right
i had a feeling on that day i think you
told me i was like i have a feeling
she's going to lock it i think you did
something
the day before that we were hunky dory
so that's what's annoying yeah yeah yeah
fam i could just tell literally on site
it's i get so angry when women
disrespect you
and when they hurt you it drives me up
the wall
it's on site you can't do that to my man
you can't clean up from my boyfriend
that's hilarious my man is upset
for what when he thought you man with
hunky dory
and you man were just giggling and lips
in
nah rolling with the punches having a
jolly good time and then you lost good
old-time fun
because you want to pursue your own
adventures nah not my boy no
not not today is on site
that's hilarious mum fam i get more
i never get angry about [ __ ] that
happens to me but when happens to other
people yeah
i know from living the stories you've
told me obviously a lot of this time i
can't say on here but it's obviously
something always told me fam
oh my god people are mean to me
in the in the last decade you've been
through it
oh i've i've met malicious people in the
last decade
you ha i don't know how you're alive i
don't know how you're alive today i
would have talked to myself
there's some things you go through that
you've told me i'm thinking
how are you this evil how are they that
evil do you know yeah yeah
yeah and how have you survived this
because there are days where i just
can't
take it that was me i couldn't take it i
couldn't take it
i honestly couldn't take it oh it's
hilarious it says exactly what you say
certain things that don't hurt me as
much well it clearly did at the time but
i didn't know but when it happens to you
what happens to my close boys i'm like
damn
like why he doesn't decide he's a nice
guy a fam he's a nice guy i try to be a
nice guy oh so do i
but it is what it is man this is the
game's game it's it's it's
it's one of those things i said one day
i'm going to write a book one day i'll
write a book it'd be a new york times
bestseller
because i've been through it the way it
works
like one of the first episodes to be
fair um
wow but yeah it's like
but it makes you a better person though
oh of course when you deal with people
who are intentionally trying to be
horrible
it's just like i'm not going to sound
perfect like i've done things that to
[ __ ] people over
but i've never intentionally done
something to hurt someone's feelings on
purpose do you know what i mean
of course i know what you mean but i'm
trying to think whether i have or
haven't done it
um i i like to don't i like to i don't
think i have
yeah because i'm not a malicious person
like that yeah i'm neither am i but
there's certain things that people will
do to literally just
[ __ ] you over i'm to be fine i'm
sticking with it because i don't think
i've because
everyone i don't know if i've said on
here but you guys know i'm a
consequential thinker yeah
i like to i always plan out my actions
before yeah and i
i need to make sure everyone likes me
i'm tj i need to make sure
everyone likes me so i would never do
anything on purpose if you don't get
that reference by the way
oh yeah recess you need to do research
if you don't know yeah if you don't know
your recess knowledge like that that's
your own business that's the legion
um but yeah i i've got a fan request
before we go down a rabbit hole yeah
yeah
i've got a fan request
let's track it down
yeah cool
this one i apologize to the don who sent
it he sent it
[ __ ] ages ago october end of october
he sent it
it's january fun i'm aware i'm aware to
be fair
there's there's quite a few in a
stockpile we need to go through there's
quite a few in a stockpile so guys
bear with us like i know you guys send
us stuff day in day out whatever
we've got loads and it's okay we've got
loads and we're going to start
proofreading them as well
only the creme de la creme will make it
yeah because
this is entertainment i know some of
it's working also some of the grammar
like i can't keep reading
obviously we read what you guys write
yeah we read it out loud and then people
send for us in the comments like because
we
read it right big man
right this one's actually short and
sweet perfect cool so friend chris
uh big fan
um the last time me and my mates got
together for a little party
with just the boys um one of them is
bisexual
and long story short one of the guys is
bisexual one of the guys is like
bisexual so
group of boys got together one of them's
bisexual long story short he ended up
sucking off one of our other mates
who we thought was straight i caught a
glimpse of it unfortunately
drinks were involved and the rest of the
night was real uncomfortable
nobody has spoken about it since how do
i talk to him about this
that is juicy saucy
saucy also i don't think i've ever met a
male bisexual my entire life
maybe you have maybe i have obviously
maybe i have but no one that i
actually hey maybe you have
i'm such an idiot sorry i'm so hey
hey maybe maybe
right sorry give me the give me the
recap sorry
i went on a tangent mandem they're all a
group of guys
they're they hang out one of them is by
everyone knows he's by is
it's all good we're all chilling there's
drinks involved
and then i'm walking to
so it's all the fellas one of us is bi
we're all at a house party drinking
having a good time i go to use the
toilet
as i'm walking down the hallway and
looking through one of the bedrooms
i'm not going to put you in it i was
going to put you in you know i was i saw
your face i'm not going to put you in it
a few hands getting sucked off sucked
off he's getting his skin sucked off him
right so anyway i walked past and
the bye brethren is sucking off a
bedroom that i thought was straight as
an hour
and they're all in the same group
they're all in the same friendship group
wow
but only i saw it and i don't go around
my mouth but only i saw it
and he's getting sucked off and i walk
past
cover my mouth and just hurry up and
then he looked what was that
and he grabbed his head i heard
something
what did you hear that thing yeah that
mouth wipe
oh god funniest thing man said how do i
talk to him about this
oh that's sticky
okay oh god
very sticky my initial gut instinct was
to not say anything at all if i'm the
guy that sent this thing is to not say
anything at all purely because
obviously the buyer guy the bi-bredrin
is obviously buyer he's happy to be
buying like he's open he's
whatever he's got no issues whatever
whereas
so wait the buyer guy did the sucking
right yeah he got sucked off yeah no
okay so the guy that got sucked off by
the bisexual friend
is also i'm assuming by curious clearly
he's clearly bicurious so
i don't think it's your place to
announce anything
it's obviously you've seen it but that's
just because
you are happy to see it you happen to
eat but the right place at the right
time kind of thing it's normal
business no way it's not business but
theirs so
whether it's it shouldn't be sticky for
you more time is 10 times stickier for
him
obviously he's by curious and he doesn't
know what to do and blah blah blah
but he tested the waters got sucked off
and he clearly enjoyed it yeah
yeah you know what i mean so it's my
personal advice is not your place to
because who does he want to speak to
does he want to speak to the bible or
does he want to speak
he don't want to speak to the bible you
want to speak to them this is the
bible's
area of expertise this is what he does
okay oh
man um i don't think it's your place but
that's my gut instinct my gut instinct
is also yeah as
hearing you say that i'm thinking in my
head it's like
would you feel the need to talk to him
about it if there was a girl in there
sucking him off
there we go if not then you have no
reason that he should have to tell you
about this one that's a very good point
his sexuality is his own deal brother
like he's none you do
he he doesn't owe you [ __ ] because just
because you thought he was straight
and he gives off the impression he's
straight and maybe he said he's straight
that doesn't give you the right to
to need to know answers as to why he's
getting started by a guy
it's none of your business yeah at the
end of the day so uh yeah i would say
yeah
to be honest bro for the sake of your
relationship with this this don
if it doesn't bother you then just leave
it and if it does bother you
especially leave it it's none of you
yeah it's literally none of your
business at the end of the day
um but god that's juicy
god that's true if that happened in our
friendship group oh gosp
fun you already know me yeah i would be
if i was the one that walked down to the
toilet yeah peeped in i thought
you would everyone's hearing me i
wouldn't be able to jump
i would hear you from oh my god
i hear that upstairs i'm cling clinking
downstairs
oh my god it's just the sheer shock of
it
whatever our boys getting unsucked
it's not even a nah man it's just the
sheer shock of it
the sheer shock of it i'll laugh my head
off
laugh my head off i'll bust through the
bedroom what's going on
to see one man get a neck off another
bridge and i would howl
i would howl say you dirty buggers what
are you doing
oh that's hilarious that's hilarious
that's also juicy but that's stickier
yeah but i can see why
obviously don't feel bad in terms of
just because we've said
it's none of your business don't feel
bad because 100
i can see where your head's at you'd be
thinking what the [ __ ] is you obviously
you're
your mind is doing backflips yeah yeah
yeah torn
absolutely tournament that's what it was
for the sake of it like sometimes you
can only get the best advice from
someone who's not emotionally invested
in the situation very true
third person perspective the person
perspective is sometimes the best
because when you're emotionally invested
in something you can't think logically
yeah you think like that he has to tell
me where i'm going of course
i'm just going to confront him or i
can't keep this to myself all this stuff
like once you take a deep breath and
just
take yourself out of the situation just
think you know what yeah regardless if i
thought you were straight or anything
like that like
it's his business yes and what good is
me grilling him what good is it gonna do
yeah it's just gonna make him
more of a reclusion you're gonna leave
you're gonna force him to put
a title on what he is yeah you're going
to force him to say okay then
well you're right i am straight or i'm
not straight or i'm bi or i'm this like
don't
force him into a lane like you
confronting him about this is going to
make him have to
look at himself in a way that maybe he
doesn't want to look at himself maybe
he's just happy maybe
one day he just woke up and fancy gets
sucked off by a guy just to see what won
and that doesn't mean that he has to now
be called a bi or whatever like
it's just just leaving to do his thing
in it damn
but yeah that's juicy in a friendship
group
i almost want to see that just because
it's so
yeah yeah the gossip will fly off i'd
have to tell you if i saw it from two
other bedrooms
i'll sprint to tell you and i'll say sit
down
sit down i have to tell you what i just
saw
nah drag me away
i'll be fuming fam get your heels in
your titties and get out
i talked to my bridger for a second
oh i'd be so angry up until you told me
oh fam
i know you would you know what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing i'd be so
angry ma'am i was slapped
you know that time where i slapped you
have i said honor yeah
you have a few men
i know you were that's what i'd have to
do with that night if you were like
james what the [ __ ] i would
quickly just like not follow through
yeah just like just a tap like sharp
sharp
stop talking we haven't got much time
because they've heard me they've heard
me
and i've sprinted upstairs
sprint it downstairs we haven't got much
time
hear me out i heard i saw such and such
sucking off such and such i feel like
you're you're a
[ __ ] lie oh my god
that would be hilarious i'll say trust
me when tom gets downstairs
his lips are going to be swollen that's
your evidence oh they're going to be red
and swollen oh my god
i didn't need that vision sorry g oh my
god it's hilarious
swollen you know oh that's funny jesus
that is funny
i've got a scenario go on okay
um let's say
[ __ ] outside before you work you work
at nine to five
but you work in a cemetery oh god
and they offer you
so you work in nine to five you work in
a cemetery and you have to work over
like
a halloween weekend kind of thing but i
offer you a grand an hour
but what you have to do is you have to
dig graves
and then fill them up that's all you
have to do all you have to do with
throughout that whole weekend is dig up
graves
fill them up dig up gracefully up but
there's a there's murmurs going around
murmurs that mandem just get joked in
that cemetery
dropped and filled joked and dashed into
the cemetery tig into the [ __ ] burial
what are you doing are you gonna take it
a grand an hour a grand an hour and
you'd have to do
you have to do two nights so nine to
four five to nine five tonight so it's
not overnighting
so 5 p.m to 9 a.m 5 p.m to 9 a.m on a
weekend
oh
so what's five to nine so that's twelve
eight hours
five i know it's not overnight no it's
not overnight five times twelve that's
it's like 15 hours 17 hours
so 12 hours 17 4. so 34 times well stay
four grand
so after this weekend i'll come at 34k
but i have the risk manager getting shot
how strong are these murmurs fam
oh they're strong you knew about the
moments before you took the job
oh and if you take the job i've got to
meet my quota so i can't just hide in
the warehouse oh just look at work
fam you have to work they say you have
to hit this quota by this time today
and the same again tomorrow before you
get your 34 bags jesus christ that's
intense
34 bags but there's murmurs fam there's
murmurs that there's a serial man on
loose that he just loves to
hang around people up he loves to hang
around cemeteries on during halloween
because that's where all the fun's at
jesus that's where all the fun's at
and he stabs them and puts them in the
grave that they've been digging and
covers them
dips jesus i know when
you're digging digging digging out
you're doing your job you're doing your
job
let's say you've taken the job you're
doing your job normally but you've heard
the murmurs
and you're digging you're digging one
grave digging one grave ding where grave
all of a sudden you hear it you hear a
thud where because there's no
there's no um there's no cough in there
because you're digging up the [ __ ]
thing to me yeah yeah yeah
space but you're hearing a thought
you're like what's that
and you know when you scrape it like
that with a with a shovel so you can try
and see what you're looking for
all you see is that one arm i'm not
taking the tape okay
i'm not seeing i'll tell you why because
i will never hit my quota
because i'll do two scoops and i would i
was
i would just look and those
if i heard a rabbit go past i'm swinging
my
eyes i'll be close and i'm swinging the
shovel
i won't get anything done don't you come
back i have bags under my eyes
i'll be petrified you'll be taking
monsters for bounce but
i'm not hitting my choir 100 that's
hilarious any
little shuffle i'll be petrified
petrified
oh but 34 bags for a weekend is money
that solves everything everything
i've got another question for you after
i'm not taking it i'm not taking it it's
just like
it's too risky yeah and a hundred
percent i'm not meeting my quarter and
that's just two nights to start if i
made it through the first night
i'll be shaking together okay okay okay
okay let's say
let's say if you do the first night
successfully
they give you five but if you do the
second night let's stay for you you get
50.
same rules apply he could he could come
on the saturday he could come on the
sunday
but he's coming will okay so he's coming
donnie's has no mom he's doing it you've
seen it on the news like all right he's
the about
he's about he's about no one knows what
he is the only one he hasn't hit
he's he's in an area he's an area code
he's in a plus four or four
he's about jesus so it's five to
five five bags on a saturday you get 50
bags on a sunday if you complete it
or monday morning by monday morning if
i'm still alive i get 50k
yeah 50 bags oh god but you have to
if you do saturday you have to do sunday
oh okay
what have pointless then there's no
point even getting the five
if i have to do sunday then there's no
point doing the five
true but still 50
is healthy is my wife is
is my life worth 50 bags but you might
not die though that's the thing i could
i could take him out
you could take him out no one knows what
he looks like i'll threaten him if i saw
him from a distance
i will scream and threaten him all right
okay but
um ah would i do it or not
let me think for one second would i do
it or not 50 bags griffin
digging graves
50 bags at the end of it
i think i'll do it 50 bucks is a lot
tax-free oh yeah yeah cash
cash cash pinkies 50 pound notes i'll do
it
okay boom let's say you do it now that
you said you do
so on the last day on the sunday like
let's say it's let's say it's midnight
you're digging you're digging you're
digging you hear a little rustle in the
background
and scurry obviously you do your your
look back thing you do your look back
thing and you're like okay
no one's about continue digging continue
digging here another one
you like this i can see it now
obviously because you're digging a grave
you're in the grave in it digging it up
and then you
you just look you see your hand like
that
like a meerkat i can see it now your
head peeps up
it's just looking right it's sweet in me
i can see it
so yeah scurry around scurry on you here
third one yeah like
[ __ ] this you get out the grave and you
scream who's there
who's there nothing no answer all you
hear is like the whistle of the wind
everything
you can hear kids like on the streets ah
halloween
okay [ __ ] it no one's here i'm terrified
you go back into the grave
you do your last couple things but you
start you hear like um
you know when you're in the woods and
you step on a
little twig thing hear it snap yeah yeah
all right someone's definitely here
someone's definitely here you hop back
out again now
if anyone's here make it none or else
or else and then obviously your face
let's say you're facing this way and
then you just hear someone
dart behind you like just pass me just
past you
ah my knees will buckle i fall in the
floor
you just hear some duck and you look
back like no one's saying you look back
again no one's there
nah i'll try fam if i look back if he's
definitely just passed past me
and i look back take it
i'll jump on my knees and i'll scream
i'll say please stop
this halloween killer how did you stop
come on i'll be like big man
let's work something out i'm getting 50
bags at the end of this year if you let
me run these graves
please i'll be sobbing i have snot and
everything and that's right please i
have a family
i've got people that need feeding you've
got the shovel in your hand
you're like [ __ ] it you're amped up you
hear another one you just swing your
shovel
you make a connection you don't know
what you've hit
you're not okay but you've hit it in a
way that you can't see what you fit
so i just swinging bang you hear a loud
thud you've made a connection and you
hear something drop
i'm running i will never i wouldn't
check i'll run i'll run
i'm not checking who or why is that next
morning you wake up you found out it was
your brother trying to come and save you
because he's heard about the thing
of course it is he's heard about the
halloween killer as you call it
yeah yeah and he's dead you're not a
murderer
for 50 bags why is this a thing
um what do you want me to say what do
you do what do you mean what do i do
what do you do
where mexico somewhere
someone i'm starting again i've killed
my brother i can't let my mom in the eye
i'm starting again bear in mind you
don't have to 50 bucks because you ran
away
i've got nothing i've got my own account
yeah i won't even make it to mexico
[ __ ] i'll i'll go to the republic of
ireland
i don't know where i'll go isle of wight
somewhere i haven't been isle of wine
decades i've never been to the isle of
wight why have you been to the isle of
wight
but we used to go when we were kids like
i think we've been like two or three
times
i don't know why i think it was like
back then it was like a destination kind
of thing oh i think it's similar to
what's that thing called center parks
they've got like a center park steam oh
okay i believe going i believe um
i don't know what i'll do like
i've killed my brother
i've killed my brother i thought it was
the halloween killer
i've got i haven't got my 50 bags
i'm out of a job because i dipped
midshift midshift
and there's a warrant now probably a
warrant out for my arrest oh there's an
apb for sure
actually no it might not be for urs
because the only other
i mean they might suspect you but
they've got their proof yes
there is no proof you've taken a shot
to be fair i'll probably turn myself in
i'm lazy fam
i'll pack my bags in a hurry and i'd be
like where am i gonna go
and then i'll just be like what am i
doing i'm too tired to be spending the
like the rest of my life on the run
let me just go pen and see how it goes
let me firm it see how it goes let's
affiliate with someone
inside yeah just get a nice little life
for myself in there you never know some
people get accustomed to
incarceration i'm pretty sure they do
dude fam
visit me please visit me
you'll be sectioned fam you'll be sexual
i don't think they'll allow visitors
brother
ah you just spaded your brother true
true true
i'd have to i'd have to tell these man
it was
i'm nuts these men will have to think
i'm nuts in there you'd have to go in
like
crazy tourettes tourette's
and then just these man i'm like why are
you in four families like brav
my brother just said two two thing you
know what yeah and it's going in there
you know who i am
sometimes a man says to me i had to snap
i don't even know why i blacked out cuz
i don't even know
next thing i knew my brother was dead on
the floor cause
i hated that [ __ ] anyway and never like
swear down all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah and minor things minor things no no
i'll i'll be shaking in bed only my bunk
mate will know what's going on
he would only know he
imagine like 1am you just hear your cell
door open just hear it unlock and it
just
because everyone knows the truth
everyone knows the truth everyone knows
the chief everyone knows about this
halloween murderer
ah i'll free my anus up
oh my god i have to
my anus of my life i'm slitting my
throat
i'm slitting my throat it's my anus all
my life it's my life
because i'm slitting it i'm slitting my
own throat
slitting my own fries oh [ __ ] i didn't
do word in confrontation like that
i don't do well in confrontation like
that like
i don't know i will have to i'll
question them i said what the [ __ ] do
you man want yeah
now what actually is it to be fair i do
uh
i don't know man i don't know like
i'll have to teach these man skills i
have to bring senators hey yeah so they
said your value yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like anyone never been interested in
jiu-jitsu i got that
um i i've got origami nah
the
your cell could do with a bit of a
spruce i couldn't
keep my bam i can sort your man out i'll
do anything and one of them is like i
bet you will
i bet you will spread him he can that's
the thing thing is i say i said i'll
free not free up my anus i couldn't
because if he says turn around and bend
over i really i really couldn't i'll
turn around and slit my throat
on what what are you sleeping on i have
to find sign after i have to manifest on
a makeshift site
that night because i know i'm not
surviving that week i already know that
people that watch this and know me know
i can't handle those kind of situations
no you can't you're crack
you're at yeah i'm not going to jail
and i'm not going to hell either firm
still it in my friend i think this man
do you want to start a pod
anything please fan please something
please tell me what it is you want
nothing oral and nothing penetrating
i don't want anything in my mouth or my
ass and i'll do it
would you toss him off yeah rex
if man said wipe me off and you you
survive
handy jay and he asked a night in your
mouth
why is my mouth involved he's not you're
not penetrating your mouth
but i just have to laugh yeah spray my
hang out no
no that's too much oh no okay okay okay
no okay that's humiliating
of course it is i can never live that
down handy jay
yeah but he also has to tap the dick on
you you have to tap his dick on your
cheek
twice i'll do that twice i'll do that
i was staring in his face are you really
making me do
are you for all cause are you even
enjoying this
[ __ ] sake
and now just done yeah
cool i'll wipe my hand on your shirt let
me go sleep man
oh these abs he's going to be topless
thomas is sweating
[ __ ] he just wipes his hair yes i
promise me it's a one-time deal
because he can't come knocking tomorrow
oh he will if he comes knocking
tomorrow's beef
he does what he wants he owns the prison
oh you want the main dog he's the main
dog
this is day one i'll have to scrap him
okay
i'll have to swap him in public say
alpha multiple so these men respect me
at least
even if you get time i'll be like fam
lunch time tomorrow yeah
me you just me in the cafeteria
scrap fam i will grab the tray and knock
his head
i wouldn't even wait for a circle
throughout him i would grab a tray and
spike it
i will i will have to square up all
right he'd have to die
one of us is dying that day yeah yeah i
would say if i'm listen yeah
you're top done i'm not touching your
penis again
let's just get that straight it's not
one time tomorrow
cafeteria 1 pm
no weapons no bredrins if you're really
about it scrap me
scrap me if i lose i'll i will toss you
off every monday wednesday and friday
from then for the rest of my time yeah
yeah from for the rest of my tenure in
this
[ __ ] [ __ ] hole i should have gone to
the isle of wight i'd never have to deal
with this in the eye of white
oh this is a whole hassle oh i'll have
to square up for him i will have to
i will figure a way out to beat him i'd
have to oh yeah right because i'm not
losing
i'm gonna beat him then i'm the don a
man will be wanking me off oh god
yeah yeah
right i need my entire surprise that's
what we're fighting for
i said yeah nah that's hilarious
it sounds stressful the whole thing's
not stressful like the worst the story
was getting i think
i think i would have been done better on
the run um
yes this is all along fam this whole the
hierarchy in pen is just not for me
i just want to chill i just want to eat
baked beans and chill
oh i'm tired of this the baked meat was
he stole gash as well whenever he hides
why is there always this thing in pen
why can't everyone just be about
their own thing why can't we just laugh
fam
that's what i'm here for i just i'll
just need to spot her in the gym
read some books that's all i want to do
yeah organize the library maybe and
that's it yeah but
maybe get a quick part-time gig
extracurricular a few 50p in my thing
i don't know man just just chat with the
man in it
mandom just want to be alpha everywhere
i just want to be out forever there's
always a fight with them in it always
it's always a fight with these man i
don't want to fight all the time brav
i don't want to fight all the time oh
you're the funniest kid that was funny
but yeah um
am i [ __ ] yes oh
jesus cool
let me find one who have we got today
[ __ ] you know that was funny
oh i got one have you gang okay
man said um all right bro am i the also
i need some advice was having sex with
this girl in brackets first time
and right at the start and right at the
start the condom ripped
she told me just forget about it so i
ditched the condom i told her i was
about to bust and
tried to pull out but she was on top and
just forced it if you get me [ __ ]
[ __ ] i've had he said this to me
personally as well
i messaged him back next morning she
turns around and asked to go halfs
on the morning after pill and my they
also for not wanting to go halfs
considering that i had no choice in
busting
a lot of love bro the podcast is class
much appreciated
so recap um had sex with a girl first
time the condom popped
and she said forget about it she sat on
it rode him he said he's
about to not said i don't give a [ __ ]
and continue to
[ __ ] straddle him absolutely straddle
him
bust deep in her and she's like oh you
need to go half on this pill or you're
having this you
what are we saying i told him straight
you're the [ __ ] g i said as soon as
you yank that thing off
i went raw i don't care who's on top
yeah
i don't care as soon as you as soon as
she said forget about it and you just
licked your lips and said yes yes
dived in just your beef now because
the way i said to him is like big man
like even if you managed to pull out
she still could have turned around and
said i want to get the morning after
pill
are you trying just in case yeah just in
case yeah you're trying to go halves
like and then you'd have no choice then
you'd have to be like yeah because then
you definitely are the [ __ ]
if you're like if you're roaring anyone
brother yeah and they want to get more
enough to pull they want you to go half
then you have to do it like i don't
understand the beef here
like i want to make sure she took it i
want to make sure she took it
you're playing risky you've you've not
had any scares
i'll pay for the whole thing rags and
the accompaniment bottle of water
i said that baby that's it two more
glugs
make sure it swims yeah i would get the
little dentist mirror in my mouth and
just
yeah just want to check make sure it all
works oh my days yes it's an easy one
but
i can understand in the moment i can
understand your frustration
in the moment in the moment like any
girl that tells me don't worry about the
condom just take it off
that's one of the sexiest things you can
hear as dangerous as it is
it makes my blood boil my tool can never
be so hard when you just like just yank
like putting on the condom makes me
flaccid as it is
do you know what i mean so as soon as
she says just yank it off and just
[ __ ] me i'm straight back up yeah i'm
straight back up
and i'm [ __ ] her oh yeah if she's not
obviously we've spoken about this
excitement like doubled
down because like you're excited then
she said put the condom on
and then she's like take it off bang
it's like if you were like
if for christmas if like you got a
present
and it was a ps5 box and you opened it
and there's no ps5 in there but then
there's another present inside and you
open that and it's an actual ps5
you're you're losing your mind yeah yeah
that's exactly how they're gone
oh my days right i don't think i've ever
had a yacht tell me to take a condom off
um i have i have but i didn't come
inside
i have yeah only thing i've had is like
i've i'm gonna go
round one with johnny then we went round
two without i've done that round you
banged
it always well round two banged
um but yeah uh yeah i was kind of
plain and simple really bro it's like
you i can understand
but it's like it's a really petty thing
to be it's a really petty thing to
actually i can understand in your head
if you're thinking rash yeah i can
understand like in the moment where
you're thinking in your head
she actually wants me to go past her
when you're the one
who told me didn't when i told you to
get off and you said no yeah i can
understand
in your head while it's a little bit
frustrating however for you to actually
verbalize and be like
nah what are you on about that's an
[ __ ] move regardless if you're
justified in how you feel it's still an
[ __ ] move to actually bring that up
to someone
in their face and say i don't want to go
half rags it's your fault
obviously i don't know where you guys
smashed but
you always have to be prepared you
always have to have a backup like one
condom isn't enough
do you know what i mean i feel like
that's a trial and error thing and
you're going to learn from that
experience so
always carry more than one or if you're
at yard have a pack at least or whatever
wherever you had sex obviously
i don't know um but yeah you need to you
need to become instructed by coming
prepared it's true and plus if you
really really really really really want
to pull out you could have pulled out
you could have pulled out
if you really really really wanted to
you could have pulled it out yeah
so it's hard oh it's difficult
it's probably top two one of the hardest
things as a man to do but it's
it's um it's doable yeah bro we've all
done it before we have
i had to train myself my pull out game
was
weak oh my initially weak
fam oh terrible at first but you get you
you just get better it's just trial and
error just
keep doing it the better i got the more
depressed i've got as a person as well
the better i got the more depressed the
feeling of pulling out
just before you nut is one of the worst
feelings
it's the nuts just not the same fam
especially when you're a good few
strokes away as well
so if you pull out like three strokes
away because you don't want to you don't
want to be the guy that pulls out the
last second yeah
i was that guy it's just not worth it
it's just too much stress
so you pull out and then it's just
they're heated you just you guys are in
there
you can [ __ ] your [ __ ] knees and then
you're like oh my god this is amazing
and you pull out
and you're just like you just have to
knock off and she's pretending like
come on she's doing all the dramatics
and you're like she's faking it you just
say that
and then just come down up and it's all
done
it's just like what a waste of time
because if i pull out literally at the
cusp
of when i'm about to nut and you try and
put your face there i'm taking your eye
out
like the the sheer force of the amount
of nut i'm gonna nut
it will take her eye out it's a health
hazard now
do you know what i mean jesus christ is
a health hazard yeah it's disgraceful
ah but yeah um just to double down on
what james said you are the [ __ ] for
that
um specific moment you could have either
a got another condom you could have
[ __ ] pulled out or oh initially yeah
when she said forget about it you could
have been like no no no
no no no no no especially when you said
it's the first time so yeah you'd be
like
nah i just want to use one why does she
have one you know i mean it's not
it's not uncommon for girls to have
condoms either so
but yeah cool man question yeah yeah all
right guys